there's a little bit of attention
that i wonder if you can speak to where
this kind of transparency there's a
tension with privacy
is it possible to achieve privacy
if wanted on uh on a blockchain
do you have do you have ideas about
different technologies that can do that
people have been playing with different
ideas
so absolutely the answer is yes
and um but by the way i'm a
cryptographer
right okay so i really believe in
privacy and i believe
in uh and i have a devoted and um um
a big chunk of my life true guarantee
privacy even when it seems almost
impossible to have it
and and it is possible to have it also
in the blockchain too
and however i believe in timing
as well and i believe that the people
have
the right to understand
their system we live in and right now
people can understand the blockchain to
be
something that is not con cannot be
altered
and is uh transparent and that is good
enough and right now
any way to add and there is a pseudo
privacy for the fact that
who knows if this keys belong public key
belongs to me or to you
right and i can when i want to change my
money from one public key
i split it through other public keys go
on to figure out which one is silvio
all of them are sylvia or only one of
silvio who knows so you get
some vanilla privacy no no no not the
one i could talk
and i think it's good enough because and
it's important for now that we absorb
the best stage
because in the next stage we must
understand the privacy tool rather than
taking on faith
when the public starts saying i believe
in the scientists and whatever they say
i swear by them and therefore if they
tell me private is private
and nobody understands it very well we
need a much more
educated about the tools we are using
and so i
look forward to deploying more and more
privacy on the blockchain but
we are not i i i will not rush to it
until the people
understand and are behind whatever we
have right now
so you build privacy on top of the power
of the blockchain you have to first
understand
the power of the blockchain yes
you